[Aplausos]
[Música]
desde hong kong hasta la frontera con la
india pasando por el mar de la china
meridional o las islas senkaku en el mar
de la china oriental el gigante chino
lleva meses reivindicando se como una
superpotencia estricta e insaciable con
sus vecinos dejando claro que a partir
de ahora quiere ser ella la que mueva
los hilos del poder las intrigas y la
política en esta región del mundo para
ello no ha dudado en pegarse con
prácticamente todos sus vecinos tan solo
durante los dos últimos años china ha
tenido choques con malasia filipinas
vietnam corea del sur brunei japón y
hong kong y todo ello sin contar el
coronavirus la guerra comercial con los
eeuu o el choque diplomático con
australia y por supuesto taiwán no ha
sido una excepción la relación de la
república popular china con taiwán
también atraviesa uno de sus momentos
más tensos de las últimas décadas
durante los últimos meses hemos visto
amenazas económicas maniobras militares
a gran escala una activa campaña de
presión política para excluir a taiwán
de las instituciones internacionales y
también una recurrente violación del
espacio aéreo y las aguas taiwanesas por
parte del ejército popular de liberación
que es como se conoce formalmente a las
fuerzas armadas de la república popular
china y todo esto amigos ha puesto sobre
la mesa algunas
clave cómo se puede defender taiwán
acaso sería posible proteger esta isla
de una invasión que está ocurriendo en
taiwán atentos
[Música]
la amenaza del dragón rojo' el partido
comunista de china reclama taiwán su
plena soberanía sobre este pequeño
prospere y democrático país de 24
millones de habitantes tal y como ya os
hemos contado en otras ocasiones llevan
haciéndolo desde que la política de esta
isla se separase de la de la china
continental en 1949
ahora bien durante las últimas décadas
en pekín pensaron que los crecientes
lazos económicos y sociales que se
estaban forjando desde que la economía
china se abrió al mundo facilitaría la
futura integración pacífica de taiwán
bajo algún modelo especial como el que
durante años existió en hong kong
siguiendo la doctrina de un país dos
sistemas sin embargo las libertades la
democracia y la apertura occidente han
alimentado el sentimiento contrario a
día de hoy al menos dos tercios de los
taiwaneses ya no se identifican como
chinos sino simple y llanamente como te
juanes es a sí mismo más del 60% de la
población tiene una imagen negativa de
la china continental especialmente claro
está de su gobierno y del sistema
político taiwanés cada vez menos china
una posición compartida por cierto por
la mismísima presidenta sign when claro
que la mala noticia es que china nunca
ha renunciado a lo que considera un
legítimo derecho a reunificar taiwán
aunque ello implique recurrir a la
fuerza
el propio xi jinping ha defendido
claramente esa idea y ojo porque la
fecha límite que barajan en pekín es el
año 2000 49 cuando se celebra el
centenario de la revolución comunista
[Música]
y amigos lo que una vez pudo parecer una
posibilidad remota ahora se ha
convertido en una amenaza quizás no tan
improbable
no
el gobierno de sillín pinta al vez como
una forma de compensar políticamente la
desaceleración económica que china ha
experimentado en los últimos años ha
puesto en marcha una agenda nacionalista
como hacía décadas no se conocía sin
está duplicando sus reclamos
territoriales y eso está causando
conflictos en asia sin asumen más
conflictos en todo el mundo desde los
remotos valles del himalaya hasta las
pequeñas islas tropicales y las tensas
capitales occidentales una china cada
vez más asertiva se está metiendo en
conflictos en todo el mundo como nunca
antes había visto mientras eeuu se
retira miramos que últimamente china no
sale de una pelea y ya está metida en
otra y ahora tras la crisis de
coronavirus las cosas pueden ser aún
peores ya sabéis que mejor para desviar
la atención que comenzar un
enfrentamiento en el que se ponga en
juego el mismísimo orgullo nacional pero
queréis algunos ejemplos concretos pues
ahí tenemos el mar del sur de china un
mar salpicado de pequeñas islas
arrecifes y banco de arena que resulta
crucial para el comercio mundial por
aquí pasan algunas de las rutas
marítimas más transitadas del mundo
prácticamente un tercio de todo el
comercio marítimo mundial pues bien
fijaos cómo están las cosas
[Música]
el gigante chino defiende que
prácticamente todo este mar le pertenece
que forma parte de esos aguas
territoriales una reclamación para la
que no ha tenido reparos en enfrentarse
al menos a otros cinco países filipinas
vietnam malasia indonesia y brunei y no
sólo eso para defender sus
reivindicaciones china ha estado
construyendo desde el año 2014 islas
artificiales sobre arrecifes y bancos de
arena islas artificiales fuertemente
fortificadas y en las que se han
instalado pistas de aterrizaje sistemas
de lanzamiento de misiles y defensas
antiaéreas por supuesto el rechazo de la
comunidad internacional al gobierno
chino le ha dado exactamente igual
[Música]
luego en el mar de china oriental
mantiene un enfrentamiento territorial
con el gobierno de japón por las islas
senkaku una cadena de islas rocosas y
deshabitadas que sin embargo han
provocado situaciones de mucha tensión
asimismo durante el verano del 2020 se
produjo un choque entre soldados chinos
e indios en el himalaya el suceso no
pasó de una reyerta pero hablamos de una
reyerta que según nueva delhi se saldó
con 20 bajas entre los soldados indios y
la ocupación de unos 40 kilómetros
cuadrados de su territorio en la
frontera con china y en hong kong que os
voy a contar de hong kong
[Música]
china impuesto por la fuerza una nueva
ley de seguridad que de facto está
terminando con la libertad de expresión
y de participación política en la
casilla durante casi 70 años uno de los
lugares más libres del mundo y amigos
tienes una cosa presente puede que nos
pille lejos pero lo que hemos visto en
hong kong ha sido algo así como un
equivalente de lo que hubiera supuesto
la ocupación de berlín occidental por
parte de las tropas del pacto de
varsovia si nada se ha saltado
impunemente los acuerdos internacionales
el régimen político de esta especie de
ciudad-estado y las libertades civiles
de los hongkoneses
[Música]
a todo esto tenemos que añadirle la
guerra comercial con los eeuu la
imposición de aranceles de castigo
contra australia la persecución a las
minorías locales como está siendo el
caso de los uigures o por supuesto las
acciones de presión contra taiwán
durante este 2020 china ha metido la
quinta en su estrategia de acoso y
derribo y es que el ejército chino ha
protagonizado algunas de sus mayores
maniobras aéreas y navales en mucho
tiempo alrededor de taiwán incluyendo
unos ejercicios que la propia prensa
oficial calificó como un simulacro real
de invasión además china tampoco ha
dudado en violar el espacio aéreo
taiwanés en reiteradas ocasiones
cruzando con cazas y bombarderos la
conocida como línea media la frontera
que divide entre los dos países las
aguas del estrecho de taiwán
hablamos de decenas y decenas de casos
tan sólo durante el 2020
amigos durante casi 60 años la amenaza
china sobre taiwán parecía más una
bravuconada que una posibilidad real
porque pues porque aunque el ejército de
taiwán era mucho más pequeño
tradicionalmente ha estado mucho pero
que mucho mejor armado contaba con una
tecnología muy superior mejor
entrenamiento y el apoyo de los eeuu
cuya flota controlaba toda la región sin
embargo desde hace 15 años todo ha
cambiado
si no está ejecutando un enorme programa
de modernización de sus fuerzas armadas
para que os hagáis una idea actualmente
su fuerza aérea tiene más aviones de
cuarta generación que todos los aviones
de la fuerza aérea taiwanesa está
afrontando portaaviones destructores y
buques con capacidad de transporte
anfibio ha desplegado más de 1000
misiles balísticos de corto alcance
apuntando directamente hacia taiwán
realiza continuamente maniobras rodeando
la isla e incluso tiene una división
informática cuya misión es lanzar
ciberataques contra elementos
estratégicos taiwaneses y estar
preparados para congelar sus
comunicaciones e infraestructuras clave
llegado el caso así que por primera vez
la idea de una invasión china no parece
algo descabellado lo que nos preocupa es
si en tiempos de guerra nuestros
sistemas de mando y control pueden
funcionar sin obstáculos si el país
todavía podría estar bajo el mando
efectivo wanting diputado del gobernante
partido progresista democrático y
presidente del comité de defensa pero
claro llegados a este punto seguramente
muchos estáis pensando pero enrique los
eeuu siguen comprometidos con la defensa
de taiwán así que que puede salir mal si
es verdad pero el problema es hasta
dónde llega exactamente ese compromiso y
es por sí mismo suficiente atentos
la ambigüedad estratégica
cuando los eeuu cortaron oficialmente
sus relaciones con la república de china
con taiwán para reconocer a la red
pública popular de china de todo este
lío por cierto ya os hemos hablado aquí
en visor politiken vídeos que os dejo en
la descripción el congreso
estadounidense aprobó la ley de
relaciones de taiwán una ley donde se
reafirma que aunque no se reconoce al
gobierno taiwanés como el gobierno
legítimo de toda china si se mantienen
compromisos especiales con la isla
compromisos como por ejemplo reconocer
cualquier intervención china no pacífica
como una amenaza reservarse el derecho a
acudir en defensa de taiwán y poner a
disposición de la isla es decir
venderles todas las armas que necesiten
pues bien el caso es que a partir de ese
momento se puso en marcha lo que vino a
conocerse como la política de la
ambigüedad estratégica
la ley de relaciones de taiwán lo
afirmaba estrictamente que eeuu
intervendría en caso de agresión pero si
se reservaba el derecho a hacerlo ha
sido una estrategia ambigua que dio
resultados por un lado pekín nunca ha
tenido la seguridad de cuál sería la
respuesta de eeuu de tal forma que un
ataque a la isla podría haberle
conducido a una guerra directa con la
potencia norteamericana por otro lado
esta ambigüedad estratégica provocó que
los taiwaneses tampoco estuvieran nunca
del todo seguros de hasta donde llegaría
la ayuda norteamericana así que no les
quedaba otra que asegurar su defensa por
un lado y por otro mejorar sus
relaciones con china
sin embargo amigos la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es hasta dónde llega
realmente el compromiso norteamericano a
ver me explico si el gobierno de los
eeuu nunca fue capaz de comprometerse
con la referencia de taiwán cuando su
superioridad militar era enorme
realmente lo hacen ahora con una china
convertida en toda una superpotencia ojo
que no es una pregunta menor
especialmente para los taiwaneses claro
[Aplausos]
el creciente poder militar de china no
solo se ha convertido en una amenaza
para la independencia de facto con la
que vive taiwán sino que también
incrementa el precio de una posible
participación estadounidense un
conflicto con china hoy podría llegar a
ser la antesala de la tercera guerra
mundial cuando las balas realmente
empezaron a volar para el pueblo
estadounidense la mayoría de los cuales
no pueden encontrar tehuana en el mapa
será difícil decir estoy realmente
dispuesto a cambiar los ángeles por
taipei michael hunter de la universidad
george mason y no sólo eso eeuu tiene a
la geografía en contra porque pues
porque su capacidad de la zona depende
de sus flotas navales y de un puñado de
bases asiáticas al alcance de los
misiles chinos además podrían no ser lo
suficientemente ágiles como para llegar
a tiempo y sabéis que lo peor es que
esta misma idea esa sospecha que podría
compartir el gobierno chino de que
llegaba la hora de la reacción de los
eeuu no pasaría de una protesta formal
tal y como ocurrió en hong kong podría
alimentar la intervención china es decir
esta política de la ambigüedad
estratégica podría actuar ahora en
nuestros días como gasolina en este
conflicto precisamente por eso en
washington son muchas las voces que
piden terminar de una vez por todas con
esta política es hora de poner fin a
cualquier ambigüedad restantes sobre
cómo
haríamos ante el uso de la fuerza en
taiwán el bridge colby ex alto
funcionario del pentágono y coautor de
la estrategia de defensa nacional de la
administración trump y por otro deja
claro a los jaguares es que tienen que
ser capaces de defenderse al menos
durante un tiempo hasta que pudieran
recibir ayuda pero la pregunta es cómo
demonios defenderse de un gigante como
china atentos
[Música]
la defensa de taiwán
bien a pesar de todo lo que hemos visto
en one no es un país que se vuelva loco
con su presupuesto militar para que os
hagáis una idea del gasto en defensa
previsto para el año 2021 asciende a
unos 15 mil 400 millones de dólares
estadounidenses aproximadamente entre el
22 y el 24 por ciento del pib del país
según las partidas que contemos o no
contemos supone si un incremento algo
superior al 10% respecto al 2020 pero lo
cierto es que si echamos un vistazo a
los últimos 10 ó 20 años lo que vamos a
ver es que el peso del gasto militar se
ha ido reduciendo paulatinamente fijaos
curioso verdad claro que en un momento
probablemente esta tendencia ha bajado
deje de parecer algo tan extraño
en cualquier caso a pesar de esta
aparente contención presupuestaria
durante los últimos años el gobierno de
taiwán ha seguido cerrando importantes
acuerdos para comprar equipos militares
a los eeuu equipos militares muy
avanzados por ejemplo en 2019 hacer una
adquisición de 2 mil millones de dólares
para hacerse con 108 tanques abrams m1 a
2 t el carro de combate norteamericano
por excelencia
luego en 2020 la presidenta sign when ha
apalabrado otros 8 mil millones para
hacerse con 66 aviones f-16 de última
generación y son sólo dos ejemplos a los
que tenemos que añadir misiles minas
marinas y un montón de tecnología y
cachivaches de todo tipo en total más de
15 mil millones comprometidos tan solo
en los últimos dos años y aún están
detrás del f-35 lo que supondría otra
enorme cantidad de contratos
multimillonarios y eso no es todo
[Música]
el gobierno de taiwán también está
desembolsando miles y miles de millones
para impulsar la producción local
portahelicópteros destructores o cazas
propios e incluso están desarrollando
sus propios submarinos a un coste
superior a los mil millones de dólares
por unidad no está previsto que el
primero entre en servicio en el año 2025
sin embargo un momento porque lo cierto
es que puede que todo esto no sirva
prácticamente para nada
porque pues porque la diferencia con
china sigue siendo enorme y
evidentemente es cada vez mayor fijaos
si amigos china y taiwán tenían
prácticamente el mismo presupuesto
militar a finales de los años 90 pero
hoy el del gigante chino es 25 veces
mayor y evidentemente eso tiene un
reflejo directo en las capacidades de
ambos ejércitos fijaos por ejemplo en
cómo ha valorado el propio ministerio de
exteriores de china el incremento del
presupuesto militar taiwán anunciado
para el 2021 no importa cuánto gaste
como todos sabemos taiwán es una isla
pequeña si quiere luchar contra china
continental es como una hormiga tratando
de mover un árbol sao li jian portavoz
del ministerio de relaciones exteriores
de china ya lo veis lo más probable en
casos de ataque chino tal y como
plantean muchos expertos es que en
relativamente poco tiempo gran parte de
la fuerza aérea de taiwán la mayor parte
de la fuerza naval y muchas
infraestructuras clave serían destruidas
arrasadas aniquiladas y por si no fuese
suficiente aquí amigos aquí no terminan
todos los problemas además el efecto de
taiwán que no participa en misiones
internacionales tiene un problema de
entrenamiento digamos que no es difícil
encontrar oficiales que nunca han hecho
pruebas reales de fuego con armas
pesadas
para colmo la escasez de soldados es
otro quebradero de cabeza de wang no es
un país precisamente joven y los jóvenes
que hay pues prefieren dedicar su vida a
otros menesteres para que os hagáis una
idea entre los años 1993 y 2020 el
número de efectivos que componen las
fuerzas armadas de taiwán se han
reducido más de un 60 por ciento ha
pasado de 500.000 a menos de 200 mil
soldados
pero entonces llegados a este punto la
pregunta es cómo demonios se puede
defender taiwán está amigos es la
pregunta del millón
en un pasado vídeo que os dejo la
descripción nos contamos ya cuál era la
estrategia política y económica pues
amigos desde el punto de vista de la
defensa según la mayoría de los
analistas y las propias recomendaciones
ojo del pentágono' taiwán sólo puede
tener éxito dándole la vuelta por
completo a su estrategia militar esto es
en vez de comprar carísimos equipos
militares que prácticamente no valdrían
para nada a taiwán tiene que centrarse
sobre todo en lograr que la invasión
fuese una misión tan arriesgada que los
chinos la dieran por imposible y para
ello tienen que aprovechar sus ventajas
por ejemplo su geografía es un tanto a
favor de igual sólo tiene 14 playas que
se consideran adecuadas para la invasión
marina el resto de los 1200 kilómetros
de costa está protegido por arrecifes
rocas acantilados o louis de hormigón y
amigos china tendría que llevar a cabo
el mayor desembarco de la historia lo
que ya veis no sería nada fácil además
el terreno es montañoso y las
superficies planas o están urbanizadas o
inundadas con arrozales lo que deja
terreno complicado para grandes
despliegues y muy propicio para la
guerra asimétrica
y amigos esta es la clave la guerra
asimétrica
[Música]
la mayoría de los analistas y desde
luego los expertos del pentágono piensan
y defienden que ese sería el camino que
debería tomar taiwán recomponer la
reserva formalmente formada por dos
millones de miembros pero que a la hora
de la verdad puedes carecen de
entrenamiento y entrenarlos y preparando
debidamente adquirir muchas armas
móviles minas marinas sistemas baratos y
ágiles drones muchísimos drones pequeños
barcos o sumergibles autónomos minas
terrestres misiles sistemas anti arios
modernos sistemas de operaciones y
suministros subterráneos radares y
baterías de lanzamiento de misiles
dentro de las montañas factorías de
drones y misiles protegidos del fuego
aéreo etcétera etcétera en definitiva
prepararse para contener al enemigo
poder aguantar hasta que lleguen los
refuerzos y poner las cosas tan
difíciles a los chinos que éstos lo den
por imposible hablamos amigos de una
estrategia quien no requeriría de
grandes recursos y es defendida por los
expertos de washington y que parece que
ahora la presidenta sign way ha decidido
poner en marcha prepararse para luchar
en guerrillas por supuesto esto no
termina con la amenaza china también
podría tratar de bloquear la isla en vez
de invadir la podría buscar una suerte
de guerra económica e incluso podría
establecer castigos puntuales y la
pregunta llegados aquí es que debe hacer
la comunidad internacional para
salvaguardar la independencia de tigua
quedarse de brazos cruzados como han
hecho en hong kong o movilizarse en
apoyo a la isla de ser así
que se debería hacer exactamente en fin
nuestras son las preguntas y vuestras
las respuestas dejamos por aquí abajo
vuestros comentarios y ya sabéis si este
vídeo se resultó interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like suscribiros a
visual político una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]